[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is mehmet kurt who is a visiting
professor in the Council on Middle East
Studies he is an anthropologist
filmmaker and human rights activist
professor Kurtz research centers on the
anthropology of religion political
sociology and ethnography with a
specific focus on political Islam and
civil society in Kurdish Turkey and
Islamist mobilization among the Turkish
diaspora in Europe and the United States
he examines the relationship between
state policy and non-state actors to
better understand Islamist mobilisation
it's political social and economic
grounds and its influences on the masses
in comparative perspective today we'll
talk with Professor Kurt about his book
Kurdish Hezbollah in Turkey
Islamism violence and the state
welcome professor Kurt thank you very
much for having me let's start with an
overview of your book tell us about it
well the book is the first major
anthropological study of Hezbollah in
Turkey previous to my work basically
there was a few journalistic account and
few other policy papers focusing on
security aspect of Hezbollah
but nothing really tangible in terms of
anthropological aspect of this
understudied yet very important group so
the book is divided into three chapters
and the first chapter provides a
historical sociological analysis of
Hezbollah from its ideological worldview
to its violent origin and its
transformation to more civic form of
engagement I would say that basically
the available information on his
previous to this book was just limited
to security aspect so basically this
chapter kind of like provided an overall
trajectory of what Hezbollah is based on
my research and interviews with my
research participants and the second
chapter focuses on the daily life aspect
of Hezbollah members their memories of
the past their remembrance but also
their reflections on contemporary
matters in this way I analyze the group
belonging the strong group belonging the
in-group love and kind of odd group hate
within Hezbollah but also I look at the
construction of ethno-religious identity
among Hezbollah members as well as the
social segregation and the
legitimization of violence among its
members the Hezbollah is is known with
its violent activities in the 1990s
during the civil war between the PKK and
the Turkish state but less known aspect
of this violence is the involvement of
Hezbollah who are responsible of killing
more than 500 Kurdish civilians in the
Kurdish region while also losing to 300
of its own members and first the third
chapter of the book is basically a
discourse analysis of novels and stories
most of them are semi by a group
biographical so previous - mm basically
Hizbullah has benefited from other
literature's available and written by
Turkish Islamists or like other writers
of the Middle East but in the process
basically they have produced their own
literature mostly written by Hezbollah
members who are imprisoned due to their
involvement in violent activities so I
look at basically the perception of self
the representation issues the
representation of others prominently the
PKK the Kurdistan Workers Party but also
the state and the Jews and so on and
since it is a pretty prison literature
basically there is a lot of elaboration
of the prison condition
and like how basically these prisoners
remember the past and how they want to
present it to the new generations of
Hezbollah who are now more like legal
entities and like their activities are
more around civil society organizations
and lately lately around a political
party okay so what is Hezbollah and what
motivates its members yeah Hezbollah is
basically an ultra conservative Islamist
group its membership base is mostly
consisted of Kurds with some some Arabs
and Turks as well but I would say that
95 percent of their members and
supporters are Kurdish citizens who
basically were displaced in the 1990s
during the forced displacement its
members are basically kind of anti state
but in a way basically their relation to
the political Islam but also to their
ethnic Kurdish identity is quite
complicated to to to understand but
basically Hizbollah
from the ideological point of view is an
eclectic group they were influenced by
iran islamic revolution by muslim
brotherhood by the kurdish islamist
thinker side energy but also their
leaders and founders basically have been
trained and they get their first
ideological formation from the Turkish
Islamists and especially from the
national vision movement
Malika Rashad is known in Turkish so
what motivates them what is their
motivation
you had mentioned also violence they are
typically known to be a violent group
yes yeah I mean violence used to be a
prominent part of Hezbollah hizbollah
activities in the 1980s and 1990s their
motivation at the beginning was to
establish an Islamic state
however they have never engaged with
really overthrowing the regime although
this has been kind of a part of their
discussions in the nineteen
in 1990s however they got involved in
the kind of inter communal conflicts
with the PKK members and with the
civilians in the process and they were
infiltrated by the Turkish state and
security forces in the process or the
question of impunity here is quite
important to think about because while
Hizbollah members got involved in this
violent which was quite prominent in the
region in the 1990s during the civil war
they were almost never investigated or
prosecuted by the state so this
motivation at the beginning was to
basically kind of establish a top-down
Sharia regime by overthrowing the
secular secular state the Kemalists
state however after mm basically their
leader was killed and ten thousands of
their members were imprisoned and they
disappeared from public space for a few
years and they reappeared through civil
society organizations through legal
entities dormitories newspapers
magazines TV channels and later on a
political party so I think kind of their
orientation and motivation has changed
from the 80s and 90s and now they are
more basically like kind of aiming to to
establish a society a bottom-up through
grassroots organizations with religion
has a large part of the way that they
present themselves yeah dependent
depends I mean yeah definitely religious
ideology Islamism is an important aspect
of Hezbollah's understanding of society
and politics but also after their
legalization of their activities they at
the beginning they were more Universal
kind of like impacted by the universal
understanding of OMA but they didn't
have concrete relations through the
tangible aspects of Kurdish society but
after they legalized that their their
activities they realize that they
basically it's so I
they live in as the Kurdish society so I
think in that process they gain more
kind of ethno-religious aspect how big
is the Hezbollah group I would say that
through their public events like the
blast bird festival where they celebrate
the Muhammad's birthday every year in
early April
they attract about like half a million
to a million people to their activities
this doesn't mean that all these people
are supporting Hezbollah the electoral
electoral success has been quite limited
receiving around 200,000 volts so I
would assume that half a million is
their social base which is I think I
know five six percent of Kurdish society
living in Turkey so how did you come to
be interested in studying Hezbollah I
knew you you grew up in Turkey mm-hmm
yeah I grew up in a Kurdish city on the
Syrian border city called Mardan and I
grew up observing Hezbollah and this
urban conflict between Hizbullah and the
PKK and obviously the state violence
that was was an important aspect of
daily life in the last 10 15 years
basically there is a growing interest in
Kurdish studies and in curse and in
general so in this new wave of Kurdish
studies basically we see many people
working on understudied overlooked
aspects of Kurdish society and politics
so Kurdish nationalism concerned with
insurgencies mainly the PKK the gendered
mobilisation Kurdish women movement
Turkish Islamism and so on have been
studied but basically there wasn't any
study about the group before I started
doing this work and in a way it was it
was quite difficult to work with this
group because for about twenty years
they have been underground quite violent
and no one really was willing willing to
kind of encounter this past but at the
time when I started working on the group
basically there was a
relatively peaceful environment that I
could conduct my research talk to the
former members of Hezbollah but also the
current members of the his Malayalee
ated civil society organizations or
other entities
I was well-placed to do this study
because I studied theology and in my
undergraduate degree I speak Kurdish and
Arabic and basically initially I knew
just two people so I started from there
so let's talk about the methodology for
the book how how did you go about
getting the research that you needed
yeah as I said initially I just knew to
two people who one of them was was a
person who I knew from high school years
and another one from university years
and I knew that these people were
involved in Hezbollah during their
teenage years for two three years but
then they left the organization so I
started talking to them I visited this
person basically who was former
Hezbollah member currently a Sufi and an
imam working in a mountain village so I
visited him and we together visited his
Sheikh and I wanted to talk to him
although I I have known him for more
than 15 years we have never really
talked about this issue and the book
starts with this testimony basically so
as an anthropologist basically I have
done a lot of participant observation to
public events seminars conferences
celebrations rallies I visited these
people in their workplace in their
offices and also I've conducted in-depth
interviews but basically based on
snowball sampling that's a person I talk
to vouch for me for another and I had a
few gatekeepers basically who
facilitated my access to other members
and eventually I have talked to about 50
people half of them agree
to basically speak to me on record and
in a way a kind of I managed to talk to
ordinary members people who have been in
prison due to their due to some
allegations of their affiliation to
Hezbollah the members and leaders of the
civil society organizations law years
but also the members of wider society
basically who have known this group
through their kinship and like family
ties or neighborhood and so on so in
talking to these people what did you
learn about the daily lives of the
people who are in Hezbollah yeah does it
vary tremendously or not so much
I I think the the second chapter of my
book mainly deals with with this issue
and I've learned a great deal first of
all I have managed to understand how
Hizbollah members basically operated in
urban spaces through very secretive and
strict measures of security but also
basically I I was able to see that the
gender issues the perception of self and
like how basically they they engage with
they engage with each other and their
ideological training their businesses
and so on but the most surprising part
of it was basically this challenging
emergent issue of their engagement with
their Kurdish identity because there is
this tendency in Kurdish society because
of their involvement in the violence
usually supported or at least like
facilitated by the state there is this
tendency to basically reject curtisha's
bola or Hezbollah members of not being
Kurd so not doing anything related to to
the Kurds instead I've noticed that
basically all of these people had a
strong sense of Kurdish Ness but mostly
constructed based on religious their
religious ideology and quite static in a
way that like
I have noticed that they did not really
engage with the changing and
transforming aspects of Kurdish society
and Kurdish politics but what they
wanted to do is to create this ideal
Muslim ideal and kind of like you know
transform the Kurdish society based on
these ideals recreating references
engaging with the figures of the past
such as Sheikh Saeed or Saladin and so
on and so on
so so for people who aren't in Hezbollah
and living amongst them if they weren't
seem to not be going along with their
particular religious tenants would they
find themselves in trouble or some kind
of violence would happen to them depends
on where it is taking place but
definitely it happened in the 1990s
first of all it happened to me was in a
boarding school and there was his blue
our members forcing people to do prayers
and those who did not agree or do those
who reject it basically were beaten up
but at the same time like this ultra
conservatism basically manifested in
itself to to to attack like basically
like secular people mostly human but and
and some of them resulted in execution
so going Jewish for example and Islamist
feminists figure was was killed by
Hezbollah in that process new to this
processes but later on I think they
developed more tolerance but or at least
they came to an understanding that these
attacks are not good for their
reputation and perception so now I think
they kind of do more legal protest
instead of like putting pressure
inflicting physical violence on people
although in the recent years we have
seen that Hezbollah again appeared in
public spaces armed and executing
several Kurdish activists in 2014
and the Turkish government does not step
in and do anything about this
this is a very important aspect of how
we can understand Hezbollah because in a
way they have their own agenda they are
not a proxy of the state but definitely
they collaborate with the state in the
past this collaboration has been through
executing the PKK members or the
activist figures or working for the
government we could say that working for
the government in recent years also we
see basically their collaboration
transformed into a legal collaboration
so for the first time we see the
Hezbollah affiliated political party who
depart the party of God or the freakos
party have met the government
representatives they have been provided
more space their activities are
facilitated there are civil society
organizations receiving the governmental
money and support through projects and
other other means so definitely there is
a strong connection between between the
Hezbollah movement and the state as it
appeared to be so what do you
alternately conclude in your book so as
at the beginning of my talk I I
explained basically there was the single
simplistic security focused perspective
on Hezbollah so in a way I think my
conclusion to provide a more nuanced
anthropological account of this
understudied past so in the in the
historical sociological analysis of
Hezbollah basically I've provided some
some information that wasn't really
available to some Hizbullah members
themselves who basically after reading
the the book saying that we didn't know
that this existed on the other hand I
think my contribution through this work
was to present the intertwined dynamics
of ethno-religious identity among the
Hezbollah members and how it manifests
itself in the daily life
but also I think an important element of
it was to make sense of how the violence
occurred to be how the violence was
legitimized to where towards their
Kurdish counterparts the PKK for example
and how basically the processes of
violence and the layers of identity
formation among kids without members
okay
so what are your next steps are you
going to be drawing on this this book to
create another book or what are your
plans moving forward so while working on
his bola basically I have noticed a
proliferation of many Islamist civil
society organizations operating in the
Kurdish region so I wanted to expand my
research and do more work on these
organizations especially following the
first political clash between the Gulen
ists and and the state basically there
was a lot of transformation and
replacement of this powerful
organization but also when I basically
finished my book it it occurred to be
around the same time when Isis invaded
the northern Syrian town of kobani
and I have observed within months
basically that many people either joined
al-nusrah or Isis or the Kurdish forces
the ypg and ypj so I wanted to conduct a
research on youth radicalization and
civil society and State in Turkey and
I've conducted an ethnographic fieldwork
with about 15 civil society
organizations but also with many young
men and women in this regions across
Turkey Syrian borders at the time when
basically everyone was talking about
this radicalization trajectories so that
is my most recent research but at the
moment I did I kind of I have published
a few articles from there some are
forthcoming so will you be looking at
why people join forces with certain
groups as part of your work yeah I
provide the consent
shall frame framework vibe basically
people end up in these decisions so what
do you think the future holds for
Hezbollah in Turkey I mean definitely
they are more powerful now they have
more social ways legalizing their
activities provided a space to Hezbollah
and related organizations to expand to
reach people without any hesitation
before they were just a secretive
illegal underground organization but now
they need the Prime Minister they need
they meet the the president of the
country and they can influence the
policy-making they can benefit from this
like legal governmental support and so
on the future is not clear as the future
of the Middle East we will see basically
how they will play a role within the
Kurdish society but also within the
transporter politics of of the Middle
East all right so more to come we will
look forward to hearing more from you
hopefully thank you for being here and
sharing your work my pleasure thank you
for more information about Professor
Kurt and his work please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
[Music]
you